a year of work for a four-minute flight
isn't that something we're all ready if
you are sir well let's go find out if
this
we got a breach in the perimeter
thank you
[Music]
buzz lightyear mission log
after a full year of being marooned on
this planet
our first test flight is a go
[Music]
let's get everyone home good luck
captaining
roger that
[Applause]
[Music]
waiting
just a massive robot
[Music]
that was utterly terrifying and i regret
having joined you
right here
i can provide sleep sounds if you like i
have several options summer night ocean
paradise whale calls no no white noise
is fine very well good night socks good
night buzz
you